generally speaking everything is moving
fast also rpos are moving fast and
building products is moving fast and so
it's very exciting time to be in and
especially for people who are passionate
about building great products
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders what does
it mean to really be
customer obsessed well we're going to
find out
meet charles omel the ceo and co-founder
of affogata.com
charles is an israeli entrepreneur whose
passion for personal connections and
building relationships has made him
dedicated to bringing the consumer
voices power to brands and organizations
he is the ceo and co-founder of affogata
a leading consumer intelligence platform
that enables brands to be truly customer
obsessed
by bringing their customers voice to the
right teams in the organization
i forgot this portfolio of clients
include names like wix.com
fiverr lemonade etoro my heritage
plarium and more
shareholmer welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you for joining me i fugata
yeah amazing thank you for having me i'm
very excited
it's going to be a really fun 20 minutes
talking about company culture talking
about technological evolution and
innovation and revolution
a customer obsession customer driven
results and and anything in between it's
going to be a lot a lot of fun
charles take me back throughout your
journey and tell me a little bit about
you know
how your what your part in the ecosystem
and and how you see yourself
uh you know leading up to affogata yes
so i've been in in the itec industry for
about 20 years or so
and mostly in product related
areas and in the past 10 years i've been
entrepreneurs of several
startups most of them i was the ceo and
one
and the one of the co-founders and all
of them are focused on products so i'm
very passionate about products and how
to create products and what makes
product unique and
and stayed out in the crowd um and
what we've seen is basically that it's
very hard to build products
and get the feedbacks from customer as
in real time as possible because at the
end of the day
uh everyone wants to build a product uh
that is engaging that is fun that is uh
growing and
retained and and that's a big big
challenge so that's my passion for the
past 20 years
and i'm very excited to talk about it
amazing okay so so we were talking about
the product
tell me a little bit more about the this
domain that we're in
and and this idea of customer responses
and and real-time feedback loop
when it comes to this role of product
development
yes so the world is on
on a on a shift towards everything being
online
everything is being real-time nowadays
products need to sell themselves
it doesn't matter what you share in
marketing or in
or in publication it's what people talk
about your product that makes it
unique and stand out of the crowd
also there's a lot of competition now
it's relatively easy to release
products um so we're talking about a
real
problem in terms of how to make a
product unique how to make a product
stand out of the crowd
and how to understand if the product is
good or not now
everyone is doing a lot of changes in
products new features have been
developed every day
new ecosystems are being built there are
new more and more communities
so every company needs to be proactive
and needs to really
find and search and understand the voice
of customer
now understanding voice of customers is
not trivial because sometimes customers
don't talk to you they talk at you if
you look at the open web if you look at
the review sites
etc and if they talk to you it's usually
support and things that are not working
etc
so nowadays companies need to be product
led
as they say uh and custom and brands
need to be more and more customer
obsessed in order to win the
the market and this made us think about
the fugata
and what we are doing right now um
because we try to solve a problem that
is uh
is really out there how to build better
products and our organization can be
customer obsessed
right and so you're starting with this
idea you're starting with this deep
internal understanding
when you think about approaching this
now from a startup to tackle this
problem for other
companies what what are some of the
questions that you that
you know you're concerning yourself with
because essentially you
are you know it's almost like a paradox
or you're building
a product to help other companies get
feedback on building products
yeah 100 so it's always good to eat your
own
dog food if you will and fugata is a
product that helps companies build
product and also help us to build our
product
and i think that what we are doing in a
fugata is taking
all the voice of the voice of customers
about your brand and your
product we're also talking about all the
voice of customers from your competitors
and the
and the market in general we also take
data from your
ticketing system and zendesk and support
etc and we get an holistic
view in real time about what your
customers are passionate about
what they like what they dislike and see
it also over time as a benchmark
now this is very unique because up to
this point there are a lot of tools that
are
a siloed either take data from the data
source or data source
or provide it to this a um
department in the company etc affordable
is basically a new kind of a category
company we call it a consumer
intelligence and what we do is take all
of the data that is totally unstructured
from the web and try to structure it in
a way that tells a story
we can tell that your recent editor
launch is not
as good as the previous one we can say
that the recent game that you launch
is less engaging because of this and
that we can say what are the top three
things that customers
hate about you and love about you we can
also say the same about your competitor
so we give you you give yourself you
give you as organization the tools and
the abilities
to really be proactive to the market and
truly become what
all of all of the companies talk about
customer obsession or being customer
obsessed
and that's a big big problem because at
the end of the day if you look up the
entire chapter in the open web
and in your communication system there's
a lot a lot of data
now there's a research of gartner that
says 97 of data is really unused
in organization a lot a lot a lot of it
to do with
the ability to distill a narrative right
clear narrative from all of
data and understand how can you improve
your product now
we live in a world that is a product led
growth
and products needs to sell themselves so
when we talk about product we actually
talk about the entire organization
how marketing addresses the product our
sales address the product
our customers success address the
product how the product is the product
etc
and the entire organization needs to be
connected in real time to voice of
customers
and we have ton of use cases an example
we're pretty sure no no
that is exactly what i want you to share
i i love this idea and i do and i
and you know i'm already gonna you know
get foreshadow a question for later on
we're gonna talk about
why this customer obsession which which
you know existed you know throughout
time but but now
is becoming applicable in the in the
world of data
that even perhaps five or ten years ago
it wasn't as it wasn't as applicable so
but first i'd love to hear a few
specific examples
yes so uh one of our biggest customers
and one was one that one also that
became one of our investors
after year usage is a 20-plus billion
company
that wanted that wanted to be customer
obsessed and they wanted to understand
what the customers think about it and be
proactive to
competitors they tried different tools
they tried
to develop things in-house but the gap
is is quite big because
you need to build technology in terms of
nlp
and i that really can take a lot of
chatter and distill it into
those are the people that talk about
this version about
this product and about this feature
and the sentiment around it and what
they like and dislike and see it over
time
so it's a real challenge for a lot of
companies and
we actually developed that with the
several
design partners that we've been working
with in the early days
uh to make sure that we developed this
kind of product and only
the year in the last year since we
developed the product and started
integrating customer
it really became a game changer to the
customers that we work with
we'd work with some of the leading two
of the leading
games in the world we work with the one
website development in the world also
two of the major
uh fintech companies in the world etc so
we work with companies that everyone
knows are customer obsessed
right companies like wix and itoro and
lemonade and my heritage and platikai
and vladim
and king games etc
and acorn in the fintech industry so
with a lot of leading brands that are
customer obsessed and looking for ways
to be proactive and we see it all over
the place we can see it from
communities being crazy about a specific
feature and doing a boycott
we just seen for example that the recent
adobe version
of the um photoshop
got banned by the community because
people wanted the
button of safewiz with to be in the same
place and not in a different place
right and it became a lot of people stop
stopped using it
and we see a lot of cases where someone
in an organization say something and it
backfires
we see a lot of cases the company
changes pricing for example
and the company need to understand is it
good is it bad is it working
in all of the places does it make sense
to competitors etc
so basically we built a platform that
helped brands to be proactive in real
time
uh and really obsessed uh with their
community and their customer and that's
a challenge
and a huge challenge and so
why now so you know this is you know
even if you would have told me this idea
five years ago i've been like of course
it makes perfect sense but but why
why is it not the best time to do this
because more there are i think there are
several aspects to it first of all there
are more and more alternatives
right it's relatively easy to develop
products and companies and the
consumer has a lot of options so and
it's also done boarding everything is a
all of most all of the products are a
self-serve
you can easily switch from one product
to another so the competition is also
extremely high
also nowadays there are much more places
for communities to talk
for example in the gaming industry you
have discord you have forums you have a
twitch etc
in the fintech industry you have read it
in other places um
um traditional places like traditional
social so there are a lot of places that
chatter
is being said and it's it's much
much more relevant now to gather all of
this data into one place now
another thing that dramatically involved
is also the the
the ability to extract insights from
noise because for example take a company
like lemonade or mandate you just did an
ipo
this is a generic word if you want to
understand what people think about the
product monday versus monday the day
you need to a lot of technology to
understand how to distill this data
so i think that's also something that's
been changed and i think another thing
is being changed is that
most if not all of the sales journey is
totally online
people search for product they want to
understand how to use they
they share their use case and get
feedback the community which
product they should use etc so
traditional marketing
is is less effective in terms of uh
changing the narrative of how people
perceive your product right
is your product for professionals or for
a
you know for easy on boarding is your
pro pro
product for this kind of a department or
that department etc
and people tell you what you're all
about
and i think that that's part of the
things that happen i can tell that
us as a fogata we were just
three people something like a year a
year and a half ago
and now we are 30 people and that just
saw the growth
not only in companies but also in
startups and
a lot of ecosystems there's a lot of
potential and things are moving much
much
faster than it did five or ten years ago
in all aspects
and so i think that also plays a big
part in
why things are moving fast generally
speaking everything is moving fast
also rpos are moving fast and building
products is moving fast
and so it's very exciting time to be in
and especially for people who are
passionate about building great products
that's amazing and so you're you're
building a startup here in the startup
nation or the scale-up nation the
unicorn nation
and uh you you know you're competing
against you know
everybody and you know talent is scarce
and you know how does a small startup
grow
within a year and a half from three to
thirty hopefully with really the right
talent
and and compete with you know everybody
else that is sitting even across the
street from you
yeah so that's an amazing question i
think that uh
israel has been very blessed with big
giants of companies that been
working here for example apple google
etc on one end on the other end it
really takes a lot of the talent and
it's real challenge
i think that as you said we were for
three to thirty in the past year and a
half and our planet
till the end of the year is to grow to
60 people to double the amount of people
in israel and also in san francisco
we have another office i think that what
makes the change is the ability of
people to make an impact i think the
culture is crucial
for companies that are growing we have
an amazing balance between
people that has a lot of experience and
be seen a lot of things
versus people that are relatively junior
and new to the ecosystem and want to
prove themselves
and i think that together with this
fusion we are able to take people that
are uh you know 40 50 years old versus
people that are 20 25 years old
and connect that into a working
ecosystem and a working
a a um agile place that everyone has an
impact and as the company grow there's a
lot of places that
could suck a talent for example someone
who do this product and dutch product
and we are very open in terms of giving
people the ability to lead things
one of the things that we are very proud
of is that a lot of people within the
company grew
to different places for example people
that did the sdr and are sales people
people just started as qa and our
developers people started as a junior
developers or so now senior
developers etc because i think it's
crucial for us as a company to grow
and we also just recently moved to a new
offices
which is very exciting to us because
previously we were in the garage
right so we had a small garage in
brnebrak
that wasn't the most attractive place
and i moved to a new place we moved to
bessel
uh in the 29th floor we have a nice view
and a nice porch
and you can see the sea and you can see
the the aircon and you can see a lot of
vision
and i think that's also it kind of shows
that the
uh the changes that our company did in
the past year and a half
right now you can go to the office see
the vision you can see the sky you can
see
a lot of israel in just one image and i
think that inspires people to say okay
let's work in a startup and let's create
something that i'm
really feeling like i'm part of and i'm
making a change and the technology is
very strong and i'm
working with what some of the biggest
brands in the world
i'll give you a story we just uh
recently launched our
apr of the investment and the
positioning was
goodbye focus group ello fugata the new
consumer intelligence platform
the position was very engaging because
we said
no no need for focus groups or surveys
we bring everything online to you and
your
and your customers and for example one
of the biggest
uh brands in the world contacted us from
japan
and said listen guys we're looking for a
lean startup that can help us
really understand voice of customer we
want to get data from this
this and this places we want to
integrate it into our ecosystem
which really want to be customer
obsessed like you say let's work
together right
and it was totally unexpected luckily
one of the people in the company knows
japanese
shows now she became the account manager
of that
uh account and and
you know and we're working with them so
this one example of how the world is
changing and how a small startup still
can make an impact
and have great talent with it now as as
the ceo and leader
what are some of the things that you're
you know that you're positioning
yourself with or thinking about
as you're now growing and scaling the
startup is it is it primarily
you know around the talent is it
primarily around the product
you know how i'm trying to think you
know how does an early stage
entrepreneur with a very fast growing
startup
you know what what are you challenged
with yes
so we have a thing in the company of
girl
so and it's initial for g's growth
it's crucial to have growth ongoing
growth in the company
in the organization with the with the
people etc
the other hour is recruitment
recruitment is crucial in our face we
need to
find the right people that make you know
we have a saying in the company that
happy people
create happy products that makes the
world a better place
so we're looking for people that would
one of the questions that clinton
interviews is
what would make you happy as as a
potential
employee in a fugatta uh or as a
potential partner in our journey
and so the second thing is recruitment
and the third thing is retention
we have a lot of impact with amazing
brands and we need to keep on pushing
that impact
keep on working with use cases assist
the brands that we work with
on several aspects for example we have a
lot of examples of
things that backfire for organization a
pr went wrong
some community leader that is uh
sharing negative chatter about them some
release of a feature that they
terribly etc all the time there are
suddenly negative picks
and we are there with the companies to
help them understand how to
manage this crisis how the steps that
they are doing is making an impact etc
so retention is a another thing
and i think the last star is about a
recruitment and round eventually as a
startup we need to keep on finding great
partners
for example our next step is to expand
to the us
so now we are engaging with several
partners who have also leadership and
connection in the state
so we can also grow to these places so i
think that that's part of the ecosystem
what we do as a company
what makes me feel super excited about
what we do is the people that we work
with
the partners that are part of our
journey and the team
and also the impact that you are making
to the amazing brands
uh for example gaming industry is
something that we are
extremely strong on we didn't know at
all a year and a half that would
even provide value for gaming companies
we thought it'd be more for traditional
online brands and we understood that
gaming is crucial and there are a lot of
gaps in gaming and a lot of places so
gaming fintech is also something that is
amazing for us that we're working with
also insurance tech is something that
we're very strong on
so basically a lot of places that we can
show we can show how we can see how it
can bring value
and make an impact to amazing brands
charles i love what you're doing at a
fogata
i won't repeat what i said right before
we we started recording but i i really
am
inspired by the work that you're doing
uh and uh
and and i think that it's you know the
right time the right market you know it
sounds like an incredible team
and so i'm really excited to continue an
envy and be a champion
for another another successful startup
in the in the startup nation so thank
you for these 20 yeah
we're very excited yeah thank you i i do
have three questions for you though and
not about
affogata and not about startups but
about yourself
take me back to your childhood what
fascinated you as a kid what was your
maybe your favorite subject in school or
or a passion hobby of yours yeah one
percent so
when i grew up i grew up when there were
no mobile phones
and there were no less tv right there
was only one channel in israel
and so where i i and i grew up
right next to the sea in australia so my
biggest passion was the sea
and specifically diving free diving
i used to go with my uncle and with my
brothers to the sea and did a lot of
diving when you're underwater and you
feel there is no
you don't there is no gravity and there
is no noise and it's just
almost like meditation so i think that's
one of my biggest passion the things
that i like
and i keep on doing it even now to these
days free diving
i think it's amazing and definitely a
passion a childhood passion that grew
with me
and somebody that inspires you along the
way along your journey professionally
personally wow so so you know
it says you need you need a village
right you need a village to create a
great company the village to create a
great
ecosystem uh as i said i was
entrepreneur for about the last 10 years
the previous startups were bootstrapped
without funding so it's a it's a very
very kind of different challenge
and you cannot bootstrap a company
without the help of amazing
entrepreneurs
some of them became our investors um
and i'm very privileged to have those uh
for example the ceo of wix
aviisha the ceo of a fiverr uh doctor
guillermo
who is one of the founding fathers of
the israeli itec
a lot a lot of amazing entrepreneurs and
ceos
that guided us along the way and helped
us build the fugata
and create an ecosystem and we were very
privileged and wouldn't be here without
them
uh in general i must say there's a lot
of
active ecosystem of great entrepreneurs
and ceos who help others
build rate companies we can see now for
example monday we just did an ipo
they grew at weeks and i think that a
major part of what they did was
the ecosystem there and and so we see a
lot of support and a lot of growing
companies within
the ecosystem from existing uh ecosystem
and things that's very inspiring
very very cool and what are three words
you would use to describe yourself
wow so i think that i'm very passionate
about people
so i think that's the kind of thing that
i like to do and also a lot of what the
fugata does is about connecting people
connecting people to a story connecting
people to a
movement and very passionate about
people and also about entrepreneurship
about making products about being
innovative and definitely the things
that they
described me a lot wonderful
thank you very very much this is
wonderful and best of luck with the
fogata
and i can't wait to share this with the
world thank you
yeah thank you very much
[Music]
you